okay so let me just start by saying that
uh
i've never really been to uh like a
media
public speaking training course or like
uh gone to journalism school or
something but um i'm confident that if i
had they would have told me not to eat a
peanut butter sandwich
in the 10 minutes between speaking and
then speaking again so uh
that was not a good idea but anyway i'll
try not to you know
uh get my mouth to clean the residual
peanut butter
what we're all learning agents yeah this
is all part of the kilvin learning
experience
um so let's see where we left off uh
we we went over some faqs uh during
the break and then now we're talking
about inference for the value function
and then the spirit of keeping things as
simple as possible we're going to talk
about one stage problems
uh then after this we'll talk about two
stage problems and i'll have a brief
blurb about infinite
horizon problems that'll just be two
sides long that shows that really it's
the same kind of ingredients it's just
messier
so in a one stage decision problem uh we
have
x i a i y i so these are drawn iid
from some distribution p and so this
could be you know for example randomized
clinical trial
x is the patient characteristics uh
or feature vector that takes values in
some space script x to the subset of rp
and treatments here will assume are
binary that's not really critical it
just makes things more convenient
you also see throughout this that i will
sometimes change the encoding of
treatments
it's whatever i think is going to sort
of make the uh
exposition easiest so uh i'll try to
point that out if i switch from say
minus 1 1 to 0 1 or something
as we go and then y is an outcome
which is like a utility so it's coded so
that higher values are better
and then in this case a treatment regime
or a policy is just a map
from a script to x into a
okay so it's a little bit like a a
contextual bandit problem
uh with two arms um although it's in the
sort of batch setting
okay so uh we'll define q x a to just be
the expectation of y given x and a then
the optimal regime
pi opt x so opt for optimal
is the arg max over a of q xa or this is
one of the optimal regimes
can be defined this way and
let's suppose that we pause in some kind
of linear model say qxa and x by beta
which is x0 transpose beta0 plus a times
x1 transpose beta1
where x0 and x1 are feature vectors and
beta is just the
beta0 beta1 is concatenated and then
we'll assume that we estimate beta using
ordinary least squares so beta hat
n is the argument of the empirical
expectation of the squared residuals so
y minus q
xa beta and subsequently the estimated
optimal rule then is
i hat of x is the r max over a of q x a
beta hat
and we're going to define the population
analog of beta hat to be the argument
of the same expectation or the square
the square residuals but with respect to
the
data generating model instead of um the
empirical expectation
so it's important to note i'm not
assuming that the actual expectation is
linear
but we are going to do inference for
beta star which is the projection under
the
uh linear approximation space here
under very weak conditions root n beta
hat minus being a star
it's asymptotically normal with mean
zero and some variance covariance
this is not the same one in the previous
section i'll often use sigma as a
generic kind of covariance matrix
and i'll try to make it clear what i
mean so
you have a question about this linear
model uh
it is set up in a particular way and
you're using that a
is either taking values of plus or minus
one
and uh there is some sort of redundancy
because then you can say that like you
have actually two feature vectors one
for action one
one fracture minus one and then you are
over parameterizing the beta or like i'm
like
it's like an alternative parametrization
so it's like
uh so why why this i i guess like you
would argue that this is a general
linear model uh that for the two uh
actions you have different feature
vectors and then just writing it
in this way uh but but like the
parametrization is just a bit unusual
because
uh then the parameter vector for one of
the feature
vectors which is x naught minus x one
is going to be beta naught minus beta
one and for the other one
oh this is oh gosh okay hang on yeah
yeah so
there is a typo there but uh yeah okay
like
uh it's uh yeah like
i i see that like uh this this is
equivalent to the model
that you would say that you have two
separate feature vectors or
as many actions you have uh that many
feature vectors and that's it
yeah it's cool you're right it is
equivalent this
this is called the contrast coding is
sometimes used more often in stats
because um one of the reasons is that
uh they'll often look at well one one
very simple thing would be that if you
know this term is identically zero
then that means there's no benefit to
tailoring and also
uh yeah the kind of estimates you would
construct in the original you know
if we had something that was like x
transpose
oh geez beta one you know uh
times indicator that a is one uh
i should stop writing because they're
handwriting so terrible uh
uh plus you know one for minus one then
the kind of things we care about our
contrast anyway
often you know uh and so that's this
just makes that some of the inference
more convenient yeah okay all right
good thanks okay
uh all right so uh
one interesting thing uh is when we talk
about what do we want to do inference
for
well there's the value of the optimal
regime which would be v of pi opt
and sometimes i will conflate v of pi up
with v of the
regime index by beta star but as many of
you know those are not the same thing
uh beta star does not have to index the
if i plug in you know beta star
in the q function take the r max it
doesn't have to be the optimal policy
because
there's a mismatch here between the
least squares criteria that's being used
in the definition of the value function
so sometimes i will conflate those
but they are not necessarily the same
thing but so one so what might we want
to do inference for
we might want to do inference to the
value of the optima regime say v of pi
opt
uh which is the the expected outcome if
you were to assign treatments according
to pi opt
and we can write this using inverse
probability weighting as
v of pi opt is the expectation of y
times an indicator that a
equals pi of x divided by the propensity
to assign a given x
so uh this is uh uh
basically the the horus thompson
estimator or the value but
this is just expressing this thing in
terms of the data generating model
you could have also done it in terms of
the q function uh but we'll do this
here um so
there is a question um that we're using
queue
is it the same as the queue in general
rl is it intentional
yes yeah oh sorry i didn't see the
question uh yes
it is the same uh there's only one
decision so it's not like saying we take
this action and we do something else in
the future
but it is it is intended to be um
analogous so when we do go to
multi-stage problems we'll see
similarity
yeah so that was intentional but it is
and i guess technically the definition
is the same
but there are no future decisions so
it's um
yeah and uh there was a question on
discord on the
dilemmas and the the sort of the nice
examples you showed in the previous part
of the talk uh
like where can people look for
references will you add references at
the end of your slides in the final
version or
yeah i'll add some more references to
this to this
to the slides there's also
some of this is discussed in um in our
uh we have a book in dynamic treatment
regimes uh
that came out in just this year uh
with with bushy butch seattus and marie
davidian
shannon holloway and i wrote a book and
it has some of that in there
but that it's um
[Music]
the paper is well it's very focused on
precision medicine so it's called
dynamic treatment regimes and so
uh i'll try to find references that are
also more general than just the
precision medicine kind of focus but
that has all the custom different stuff
in there too
because the question is whether the
proofs will be there
uh yeah also the papers that have the
proofs too are links to papers that have
the proofs
with all the detail yeah good
and the p and the paper that i drew all
this from i'll send a link to that too
uh yeah so this stuff this this section
here is all drawn from a particular
paper
with min chen
okay uh right so
uh why would we care about this well we
might want to we might want to show the
potential for tailing decision making in
a given context so we
went to the pi opt has a higher value
than say
pi business as usual so bau business as
usual for those who've
seen that but the idea is that you know
people do something in a particular
domain
and you might want to show that if we
tailor optimally we can do better in
that domain
there's also this idea of a conditional
value
so we might say well what's the
performance if we took
our estimated regime pi hat and it
should be a sub n here
pi hat n and we deployed it so we
estimate a rule or a policy and we say
now we're going to use it in the
population
what's its performance and so in that
case
we'd have v-hat of pi is the expectation
of y
times the indicator a equals pi hat of x
divided by the propensity
but the expectation is only over x a and
y
but not over pi hat so this is a random
quantity right
because it's saying condition on the
policy you've learned if you were to
deploy it in practice
what would its performance be and this
is relevant for
you know evaluating the performance of a
learned rule or learned regime so you
get data you estimate the
the policy and then you go deploy it how
will it perform
then something in the middle is the
average performance so uh
if you look at say uh is
so notice there's no pi here because
this is really what should
the argument to this is an algorithm
that's what be the input to this but vn
is the expectation of v of pi hat
so what you do is you average this over
all data sets of size n
that are used to construct pi hat and
that would be the average performance
and so the ipw characterization
characterization here would be the
expectation of the pi hat which is the
expectation
which would be uh of the sorry this
should be a pi hat here expectation of
this thing here over pi hat okay and
i'll fix that in the updated
that's like the expectation over for it
um over your algorithm what type of pi
opt will it will it estimate and then
what would
yes this should be this should be a hat
here right yep examiner that should be a
hat
and then this is over this thing here
this expectation this bull he denotes
expectation over the
data over training data
so the inner expectation of the p is
like over new draws of x a y
and the other one is over training data
and if the algorithm was had some
stochasticity it would also be over that
is that that's right yeah that's
actually uh
absolutely right yep that's right and
yeah and
oh geez uh i'll just write an algorithm
because if i write stochastic it'll just
be unreadable
elg okay yeah that's right all the other
uncertainty that's right
okay other questions
okay oh
uh so the average performance inference
target is about getting a baseline for
your algorithm uh so it's all
it's uh yeah or just compa the comparing
two algorithms so we might say
uh if you look at like um you know
recently there's been
really recently there's been some work
on like inference for cross validation
they're looking at this kind of thing
which is like the average performance of
an algorithm in a given domain
and so you might say should i use
one particular algorithm i don't know
let's say some kind of policy search
versus
q learning or something in a domain and
you want to compare
those two things you might do look at
the average performance
uh and see which one tends to be better
on average
that would be a reason so it's often for
comparing two algorithms that
answers your question
okay so one thing that that happened so
we've seen this non-smoothness issue
here we have the non-smoothness coming
in the
through the indicator function right so
we have this indicator function in all
three
and it turns out these things are
non-regular because of that indicator
function
which again means standard methods for
inference are not valid for modification
what also is kind of interesting uh if
you haven't seen this before is that
they don't have to agree
even asymptotically so meaning if you
give them an infinite amount of data
those three criteria don't have to be
equal to each other uh
and so we need to be very careful what
we mean when we talk about you know
inference for the value so just to
illustrate this point
let w just to make the notation more uh
compact
to find w to be y over the propensity
score and i'll assume this is known
i'll assume it's a clinical trial or
something so this is known then we can
write v
of pi hat to be uh the expectation of w
indicator a x transpose beta hat uh
so i've estimated beta using least
squares so this expectation is only over
w
a and x but not beta hat and
i can multiply inside this indicator
both sides by
root n and i can also break it up by
whether or not x transpose beta
star is equal to zero so
if it's equal to zero i can i can
multiply by n and i can subtract off
beta star
uh that doesn't affect anything and so
what happens now is if i take the limit
i get
convergence and distribution to this
thing which is expectation over
w a and x of w indicator ax transpose z
so this expectation is not over z
greater than zero indicator x transpose
beta star is zero
plus a constant um
sorry this thing here is going to be
beta star
i don't know what's going on with these
slides this here this is the beta star
here
so the point is that the z is here and
so this limit
no matter how large n gets it goes to
something in distribution right so z
is uh in fact normal zero sigma squared
where
uh sorry sigma where sigma is the
asymptotic variance of um
beta hat and so what we see is that this
thing doesn't even converge to a
constant
if we take its expectation that will be
a constant obviously
uh and it will not be equal to the
performance of beta star
and so all in this example are just just
by sort of working this out
those three methods don't have to be the
same no matter how large n is
so uh these three performance metrics
are different and they don't ever have
to be the same
in some generative models same thing
happens
in classification error right the the
test error the conditional test error
versus the average test error versus the
sort of bayes error
don't have to coincide no matter how
large n is which is sometimes surprising
[Music]
okay all right so the limiting
distribution of these estimators
uh they depend abruptly on this decision
boundary which was
the set of x's such that x trans was
beta star equals zero
and so now we're getting into this
non-regular setting where we have an
abrupt dependence on a set
and we don't know what the set is so
we might say well this set maybe has
measure zero maybe the x's are
continuous for example
but even still fixed parameter
asymptotic approximations may still
perform poorly for the same reasons that
we've seen
in the max means case and so what we
want to do is look at a local asymptotic
framework to ensure that uncertainty
about that boundary
remains even as n diverges so that
uncertainty about the optimal treatment
and standard or linear model persists
okay
okay so how do we do that we're going to
look at again a sequence of generative
models say pn
such that under pn beta star n which is
just the least squares estimator under
pn
this is the remember the population
analog satisfies beta star
n is beta star plus a local perturbation
so now what happens if you want to
construct inference measures for
a component of let's for one of these
value functions let's say
under these local models how do we do
that
well we now have our our tools that
we've learned so we can we can look at a
projection set
um so let's look at at a projection set
for v of pi opt where i'm really
defining pi opt to be
the policy indexed by beta star uh so
for any beta
let's define pi sub x to be the sine of
x transpose beta so notice
uh this is a uh a rule
indexed by beta so that you know the the
estimated uh
the estimated rule would be x transpose
beta has uh the optimal rules we're
calling it here would be exchange would
be a star
and let's define v of beta for any
generic beta to just be the value
of that policy indexed by beta our goal
is to construct a confidence interval
then for v of beta star
that's our goal so let's define
v hat of beta to just be the empirical
analog so it's just p n of w
indicator ax transfers beta is greater
than zero so here i've used the i've
used the fact that
a is coded minus one one so that um
this is the same as a equals sign of
experience with beta of course
and that's that's the rule so it's also
the indicator that a equals pi beta of x
same thing here and
then for any fixed beta you can show
that root n v
hat beta minus v of beta is
asymptotically normal with mean zero and
some smooth variance function beta
i'm sorry sigma of beta sigma squared of
beta this is if you hold beta fixed so
that's really important so
beta were fixed then this would be no
problem in other words if i gave you
beta star in a sample of data you could
estimate the value of the policy indexed
by beta star and you can get a
confidence interval
uh and sigma square to beta is given
here
this is sort of a familiar uh
expectation of a term minus its mean
so we can then construct a confidence
interval for a fixed value of beta as
follows
right so this is a fracture z and one
minus alpha of beta
v hat of beta minus a normal quantile
times the estimated standard deviation
divided by red n same thing only
plus that quantile scaled by the
standard deviation of root n
so this is a standard confidence
interval we're using the asymptotic
normality here
so if we knew if we had a fixed beta if
we had a fixed policy we wanted to
evaluate there would be no problem
of course the issue is we don't know
beta star and if we plug in beta hat
beta hat's a
one over n perturbation of beta star and
these confidence intervals would no
longer be valid
because they're non-smooth but uh what
we can exploit here is the fact that
we're using ols
so it's easy to construct a confidence
interval for beta star which we can do
again using a wall type interval so here
uh factor f of one minus eta for some
eta
just a set of beta such that n beta hat
minus beta transpose sigma hat inverse
beta minus beta it's less than some kind
of chi-squared quantile
or percentile um and if we let omega be
eta plus alpha
so this reminder alpha is the error
level of this confidence set for v
for a given beta and eta is the
error of this walled interval then a 1
minus
omega times 100 projection confidence
set for the value of
the policy index by beta star is the
union
over all beta in our confidence region
for beta star
of our confidence interval for the value
indexed by beta star
so uh again this is easy to construct
this is standard wall interval you get
these in closed form
and this will have the correct coverage
even under a local generative model
uh under some mild assumptions so here
i'm going to be slightly more formal
with the assumptions we're kind of
ratcheting up the
the technicality i guess in this in this
tutorial but
uh so here i just want to give a sense
for the kind of assumptions that you
would make if you wanted to make this a
little bit more rigorous so i'll assume
that there are
finite moments this is generally true in
any application uh
there's just some epsilon so that the
propensity score is bounded away from
zero so the probability you assigned
treatment one or minus one
given every x is uh no more than
oh what was beta please okay so we had a
question what was beta
beta is the parameter indexing the q
function
and we're looking at and here i'm
focusing just on the contrast part
sorry i i should have said that and i
think i didn't
i'm focusing only on that contrast part
so there's two parts there's a main
effect and then there's an a
times x transpose beta and i'm focusing
only on the contrast part
uh currently um
thanks uh and eric what is the i mean i
see some relationship between
the simple projection you did for the
for the
there were a bunch of means and then you
did the ellipsoid and then projected and
this but
but somehow there is an extra loss here
like eta and alpha getting added but
there it wasn't like
you just yep we're gonna prove it right
here exactly right that's exactly what's
gonna happen there's two there's two
extra pieces now
and and they're gonna show up as
additive so
maybe i'll just talk let me just yeah
let me just talk through the interval
first
and then i'll go through the assumptions
and i'll go through the proof does that
sound like a good idea
yep okay thanks uh so the
so the point here is that if i were to
give you beta star if you beta star were
given to us
then we can construct a confidence
interval for the policy indexed by beta
star
simply by doing this right and we can
estimate this
just by putting an average over the data
here and here and this is a normal
quantile
and we this estimator is just this
average over the data so we can
definitely this would be easy to
construct if beta star we're
given of course we don't know beta star
so what we'll do is we'll construct a
confidence interval
a confidence region for beta star and
then we'll take
an interval like this for every beta in
that confidence region and then take a
union of all of them
and the way we can screw this up the way
that we can make a mistake there's two
ways one
our walled interval might not capture
beta star
or it might capture beta star but still
this confidence interval might miss
right this is still a
one minus alpha confidence interval so
it has some probabilities missing
so the probability that that one of the
misses is bounded by the
sum and so our coverage will be this our
error level will be the sum of the two
okay thanks okay so uh
just some some quick technical
conditions so sigma
n this is the variance under uh
of beta hat astronomic variance of beta
hat under pn
strictly positive definite for all n and
then the way that we get these
these what's different here uh is that
you know we're talking only about this
parameter beta but there's an entire
distribution so we're going to talk
about a class of
of local alternatives or local
generative models that sort of give us
what we want in terms of beta but are
otherwise unspecified
so for any s there's a sequence p n such
that
uh if we look at this distance between
uh p n and p
uh there exists some real value function
v index by s
such that this this uh difference in
squared mean it goes to zero so this is
a technical condition that's
i don't want to really get into but it's
um if you're interested it's in the
paper and it's also in
uh say a standard empirical process text
like uh vanderheart and wellner for
example
but under this pn beta star n equals the
argument of pn of y
minus uh the q function so this least
squares estimate and we'll assume that
beta star n
equals um beta star plus s by root n
and also we'll assume that these moments
are also finite
and uniformly bounded uh for all n
under p n so um basically we're just
assuming that we have a generative model
where the
ols estimator is a one over n
perturbation of
uh beta
[Music]
okay so what so now what happens let's
look at the coverage so the point here
is that
uh if we assume a1 through a3 so this is
regularity conditions and that the data
are drawn under one of these local
generative models
so that is the the true beta is a
perturbation of
uh betas whatever written perturbation
of beta star
uh the question is what paper is this in
this is in a paper by um
uh labor and chen it's a review paper
and
generalization error it's probably the
easiest one if you look
i can uh put at the end of the slides
too but um
yeah so we there's a there's a review
paper on generalization here that we
wrote
that's in something uh and eric
yesterday we were talking about
realizability and stuff like this and
you made a comment that let's posit a
linear model but your conditions
on the previous slide are not assuming
that things are linear am i correct
that's right you're doing infinite with
respect to the projection yeah
that's correct i just want to make sure
that we're not necessarily assuming that
things
are yeah so we're nowhere assuming that
things are linear
but we are assuming we want to inference
for the best linear model that we would
fit if anything amount of data
that's right yeah thanks yeah we're
nowhere in here are we using linearity
of the q function
uh or the true q function that is the
true conditional mean
uh so i'm going to define vn of beta
star n to be the expectation of
uh w indicator a x transpose beta star n
is greater than zero so again it's just
the value
of beta star and under pn
and for any omega zero one let that be
arbitrary
then the probability that vn beta star
is in our projection intervals at least
one minus omega plus little
one and the proof is is trivial uh
but i think it's it helps illustrate
what's going on here which is the
following suppose
so we look at the probability that we
don't cover so the probability that the
value
under pn of beta star n is not in this
interval
well let's break it up into into two
cases one it's not in the interval
we're not in the set and our walled
confidence interval didn't cover beta
star n
or our world cup or did cover our base
or n or it didn't cover
now in our and our first projection said
this term was just was just zero but now
that's no longer the case
uh if we look at the probability that
our
confidence set for the for the uh
for this thing to miss what has to
happen is in this first case
well our confidence interval for the
value of beta star given beta star
treating base star is fixed has to not
cover
so that's what this is saying this
that's what this fractal z is
as a function of beta star that's the
value that's the compensator for the
value as if beta star was given to you
right uh why is that because remember
this thing here
is a union of all those sets and we're
saying beta stars in there so it's got
to
include the set with beta star and
plugged in
so we can miss by having this not
included or uh we can miss here
which says you know we don't include and
ours and our beta star and it's not in
our walled interval so we'll just bound
this above by the probability of the
wall interval misses which is this
here and the the error of this
is no more than alpha the arrow of this
is no more than eta and so the result is
eta
alpha plus a plus little of one uh so
a lot of notation for a pretty simple
idea which is just we don't know beta
star
so let's just construct a confidence
region that contains it
and because i because beta star is a
regular quantity
all this other walled interval also
works in our local local alternatives
uh and similarly for any fixed beta star
the value is nicely behaved
and so for any fixed value of beta the
value is nicely behaved and so
it's regular and so when you put them
together
you get correct coverage even under
local models
so one thing that came up uh was
how do we how do we improve this how do
we make this less conservative
uh is there some way to change the
projection and that's uh the prediction
interval that's exactly what we're gonna
do now
uh so this can be extremely conservative
in some settings so
uh and the reason is that it doesn't
adapt to the number of points near the
boundary so
if um if for example
x chances beta star was bounded away
from from
zero with probability one so it was
totally away from this boundary
then we could just bootstrap there'd be
no issue there'd be no there'd be no
points in the boundary we could have
just done
the bootstrap or normal approximation to
be no problem so what we want is we want
some kind of adaptive projection that
only is conservative
when you have points near the boundary
so how do we do that
uh well we use a pretest to identify
those x values that are somehow near the
boundary
and then we apply a projection interval
that only affects those points
okay so how do we do that well
so now we've seen these kind of
pre-tests and we've seen um
kind of these bounding type ideas so
hopefully this isn't too unfamiliar but
so what we're going to do is we're going
to sigma hat
and be an estimator of the variance of
root n beta hat minus beta star
we're going to assume that x transpose
sigma hat x is bounded away from zero
with probability one so this thing is
positive definite these things aren't
identically zero and our test statistic
is going to be x chances beta hat
divided by this quadratic form so the
idea is that this thing will be
small when x transposes beta star is
close to zero
and be big otherwise and this is our
test statistic for the hypothesis
for each x that x chances beta star is
zero right
so if this is large then we're going to
reject and if it's small then we would
fail to reject we take a sequence of
critical values say lambda n
now i'm going to define this this
quantity g bold gn of beta beta prime
to be p of w indicator ax transpose beta
greater than zero when the test
statistic is large so i have
the first argument is going in here uh
when
test disk is large and the second
argument is going in here it's the same
quantity except for the test
is small so the idea is these are kind
of the nicely behaved
parts right these are points that are
far from the boundary
and these are points that are near the
boundary and so what i want is the
projection interval to kind of only
affect this part if we can help it or if
we can do that
so first thing to note is that v of beta
star is just g n of beta star beta star
so if you plug in beta star for both
and if all the points are far from the
boundary then g and beta star
beta doesn't depend on beta meaning it
doesn't depend on the second argument
because this term here will be
identically zero
so what we've done is we've divided this
we divided the value into the sum of two
parts one we're pointing to neither
boundary when we're points are far from
the boundary
and now we're going to see if we can do
a projection that only affects
the second term questions on this
yeah there's actually a question well
maybe not on this but on maybe just the
general
even the non-adaptive projection
interval but it's two-part question are
there any finite sample results
and second part is about the dimension
how does the width scale with the
dimension of beta star
oh yeah so good question so the the
there so of course there there is work
on like uh concentration
type results uh
which are very general right i mean they
they tend to be uniform
type results and the consequence is that
the the coverage uh that we get tends to
be
you know from a confidence interval
coverage point of view tends to be
very conservative uh in a lot of those
cases so
uh you know the coverage might end up
being just identically one
whereas we might want to be 90 or 95 so
they
they do exist but they but they are
uh may often made under such general
conditions uh
so there they can be stronger results in
some sense but then on the other hand
they can be more conservative and
whereas here it's like what you're
trying to do is get
a confidence interval kind of after the
gender if you imagine sort of instead of
having uniform results over all
generative models
it's sort of at the true generative
model or a neighborhood of the two
generative model
uh although we will show some uniform
results later
uh what was the second part of the
question or what was that
oh n yeah
so in general these things become more
conservative as the dimension grows
but it also depends critically on how
you know how much
mass there is near boundary and how much
noise there is in the data
yeah okay
so uh what do we do here
uh speaking of the the you mentioned
like you can build confidence sets based
on concentration inequalities which are
very general or you can do this
asymptotic business that's based on
normal approximations and the sort of
classical distributional theory
and i see that this stuff is used for
inference right i'm trying to produce
confidence intervals for the optimal
value or for whatever i'm interested in
and these
we saw in the tutorials uh earlier this
week that we use these concentration
equalities maybe in an algorithm itself
upper confidence bound type algorithms
to maybe even direct the exploration
maybe direct
the data gathering i've never really
figured out
like like i mean both our objects that
somehow are trying to
trying to uh uh trap a quantity of
interest inside
um i might use concentration
inequalities or sort of
limiting distribution theory uh i will
have obviously more con
wider intervals if i if i use
concentration equalities
general but is there any inherent reason
that one set of techniques are used for
one
sort of use or is it just communities
being more familiar with
like do you have any any opinion on that
uh yeah i think these i think these grew
out of
so why they why why i guess maybe one
why is one used so heavily by one
community
and another by the other community
well so all of this stuff that i'm
talking about today comes out of this
goal of estimating the sampling
distribution of a thing
uh as opposed to bounding
in error so it comes out of that culture
of thinking like what's the sampling
distribution
and now we're getting bounds and things
which are moving towards this idea of
uh some of these inequalities but i also
think there's this idea that like
here we really want if they have certain
operating characteristics so 95
coverage because if it's too wide then
we lose power and so on
uh whereas in some contexts it may be
enough to just rank order
actions and so if everything is shifted
up it doesn't matter right i mean
as long as you sort of get the direction
right or the ordering right then
uh the algorithm might still perform
optimally and so that's also a
difference that
um if everything's conservative in the
same way then
across the action so maybe it doesn't
matter from a selection point of view
but from an inference part of you
make a difference well as i don't really
know i mean uh
in my own you know spare time for fun
i've tried to look at like whether
uh ucb or other things could be improved
if you had the
you know confidence intervals that were
not based on
bounds but based on estimates of the
actual distributions
in some cases it seems to make a
difference in other cases it doesn't i
don't know
oh i see interesting thanks
uh okay so now we have this quantity
that's indexed by beta and beta prime so
let g hat just be the
the version of this you would get if you
just put a put an empirical expectation
here so just average over the data
uh and you can show then that under
those conditions
uh oops sorry lambda n goes to zero and
n times lambda goes to infinity
then for any arbitrary beta under either
p
or pn written g hat of beta hat
comma beta minus g n of beta star
beta converges to a gaussian uh random
variable
with mean zero on some variance that
depends on beta so the point here is
for the first component the part that
that was sort of far from the boundary i
could use as a plug-in estimator for
beta star
so i just plug that in so notice if we
were in one of these situations where
everything was far from the boundary
and this so this term had no effect i
would just i would just have a plug-in
estimator minus the truth and that would
be it
right so it'd be what we do in normal
statistics but if we do have points near
the boundary then this does play a role
and so the idea is it adapts in that
sense and so we can use this now
to to conduct inference and in
particular
we can we can have a projection set but
the projection set might only affect the
second term
so how do we do that uh we under that
limbo we can start the confidence
interval for g
beta star for fixed beta so we want a
composite
so this beta is treated as fixed but we
plug in beta star here
uh which i call fracture m one minus
alpha of beta
g hat beta hat beta minus your your
normal quantile and standard deviation
so on
uh g hat beta hat beta plus the same
quantity so it looks a lot like we did
before only now we have this sort of
beta hat plugged in with the idea being
our union now
is only going to be over beta and
therefore will only affect that second
term that non-smooth part
okay and here row hat is just an
estimator of the variance of this thing
i'm sorry is an estimator of this which
is the variance of
g so then an adaptive projection
interval for vn a beta star n
which i'll call j n of 1 minus omega
would be the union over all beta
in our wall type confidence interval of
these
of these sets here now
so to see why this is going to be less
conservative potentially
as i mentioned if if all the points are
far from the boundary this thing here
doesn't depend on beta at all
and what you would end up getting is
just a regular old confidence interval
where you plugged in beta hat in place
of beta star
uh on the other hand if all the points
for a mass on the boundary now you pay
back to the regular confidence the
regular projection interval so it's in
between the two
uh and the exact same proof shows that
you get
consistent coverage under either uh pn
uh
or p
okay uh so adaptive projection intervals
the the the same form as a projection
interval and the proofs are equally
trivial i didn't show the proof here but
it's exactly the same
if points are far from the boundary then
this is a standard confidence interval
based on a normal approximation
uh and it limits conservatism to the
non-smooth parts of the functional
uh in this adaption adaptation to
announcement this is a theme for
inference and rl
is as far as this talk is concerned so
this is going to be a key thing is how
do we how do we make it so that we are
conservative only
only when we need to be or only kind of
where we need to be
so now a slightly more challenging
problem but also just to illustrate
uh a bounding technique here is how do
we accomplish intervals for v of
pi hat uh this is often more relevant
in like precision medicine type problems
where
we've estimated a policy and we want to
know how well we perform if we use that
on patients
uh now notice that the estimate itself
is random
right this is um averaging over kind of
future
subjects or future decisions but not
over pi hat
right so this is a random quantity so if
we have a random estimate then what do
we mean when we say to construct a
confidence interval for it
well a valid one minus omega confidence
set i would say cn
for v of pi hat is just a random set
that satisfies
the probability that v of pi hat is in c
is at least one minus omega plus little
a negligible term
where the probability is over both the
randomness in pi hat
and in cn uh and also uh
as emma pointed out in the in the if
there's randomness in in in pi had this
first stochastic policy
uh see i'm showing my bias where like
you know
and often looking at deterministic
policies in my world but yeah that be
over all the uncertainty
and so both this thing and this are
random so both the s demand
and the confidence that are random where
normally when we talk about coverage we
have the s demand being fixed
and this set being random so this is
what we mean when we see a confidence
set
in the paper that this is all drawn from
we also show conditional coverage given
pi hat uh but i i'm not gonna talk about
that today
okay so so how do we construct a bound
for this well we can let tn be the
pre-test statistic that we used in the
adaptive projection so the same test
and if we look at root n v hat of beta
hat minus v of beta hat
it's just written p n minus p of w
indicator ax transpose b hat greater
than zero and we'll just break that into
two pieces
one where points are far from the
boundary that's this first term
and one more points are close to the
boundary that's the second term
and uh this should be less than equal to
so covering all cases here
and now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to bound the second term
right so i'll write this as less than or
equal to the first term plus the super
all beta and rp
of the second term now we had looked
previously at taking sort of constrained
supes but here because it's inside an
indicator it's
invariant to scale and so if you take
any ball that contains zero you can take
all of our p and it doesn't matter
so this bound is a little bit simpler in
structure it's easy to see this is an
upper bound because if i just plug in
beta hat for beta i get back to this
first quantity
right so it has to be upper bound uh and
so
this is an upper bound on this quantity
and you get a lower bound by taking an
inf here
and so these bounds turn out to be
smooth and so you can bootstrap them to
estimate their quantiles consistently
and thereby construct confidence
intervals for v of beta hat or v of pi
hat
which i've been using interchangeably
here
so in particular for any alpha let l hat
be the alpha over two percentile of the
lower bound
u hat the one minus alpha over two
percentile of u n
then uh it follows that the probability
of v hat of beta hat minus this quantile
root n
less than or equal to v of beta hat
less than equal to v of beta hat minus l
hat over root n so the probability that
these
two bounds contain the conditional value
is at least swim myself though
okay um and that makes sense because you
took
took out an upper and lower bound and if
you take the upper percentile the upper
bound and the lower percent of the lower
bounds have to be bounds and the
percentiles of the thing that you're
bounding uh but both u
and l depend on the unknown generative
model so you couldn't actually
compute this thing so what do you do
instead well you just estimate those
using the bootstrap so you can bootstrap
these bounds and because of that
super in in fact the bootstrap is
consistent
and you can show that uh that you can
consistently estimate these quantiles
and thereby construct a valid confidence
interval
so the bootstrap analog here would be
you replace the empirical average with
the bootstrap
average the true distribution of the
bootstrap i start with an empirical
expectation
beta hat with its bootstrap analog test
with its bootstrap analog and so on
uh but you can you can compute this
quantity then and compute its percentile
that way
okay so um this gives you sort of a
a bound based approach for the
conditional value uh
that will hold under both fixed and
local alternatives
um questions on this before i continue
so can you can you go back to the
coverage definition just
wanted to ask you clarification
questions so
as you said i am this probability on the
left hand side is over every
all of the sources of randomness but you
mentioned i think
in one of your comments that you could
you also have
procedures where you modify this
definition to be conditional with
respect to like the actual pi hat that
you've picked
isn't that the more or maybe i'm not
misunderstanding isn't that
actually the more natural definition to
say i have i estimated a rule
uh now longer random i mean just give me
some
interval that tracks its uh
yeah it's just uh it's a more
complicated object and it's the only
time i me
i i think it's the only time i'm talking
about conditional coverage here and i
just didn't want to open that
can of worms so to speak i see what what
the can of worms is due to
what what's the complication
uh so then you need to show that the
well the coverage
one way to get it would be to get some
kind of joint distribution of
pi hat and then the confidence set
and then back out to conditional
coverage but in general conditional
coverage is harder to show
if you have oh i see because the
distribution of pi hat itself is
involved which is
a very it's not an easy object to think
about yeah
yeah these this cn and the distribution
of pi hat are dependent they're
dependent
but again in terms of your comment about
scientific uh goals versus
mathematics you're calling me out on my
account yeah you're right
you're right although um uh
you're you're you're all right that that
is probably more of
interest uh scientifically
uh i think that's probably the right
thing to do
but i worked uh i didn't work that out
until recently
and so my brain has always been on this
uh which has been
it's also what you'll see in the
literature so you're right this should
be given
uh yeah but it is it is gnarlier
so yeah that's a good point
um okay
so uh we tried to use the ideas that we
learned from the max means case for
inference for the value we looked at a
projection set adapter projection set
bound based sets
uh the same ideas applied an infinite
horizon case
uh and i will say a little bit about
this but not too much uh but one you
know
how do we how do we bridge those two
well least squares just become solving a
billman equation
so uh you know where you would have used
the standard clt to get a nicely behaved
estimator and now you use a martingale
central limit theorem
with a martingale estimating function
instead of just uh
sort of normal equations for these
squares but in general you get that you
get the behavior there
and then you can still apply these ideas
um and so
it just becomes more complicated but the
tools are the same uh
you know there's still you know
bernstein inequalities and clts and
stuff that work for the ml for the
martingale difference case
uh it's just it's more complicated and
so the ideas get buried a little bit in
that i think
um so uh and if one wanted the details
where can one find this like the work
worked out the whole thing with the
martingale clt
like this is it no it's not in the book
i think i don't know i mean i look at
like lion wave from like 1981
i was like i will say i would do i do
show kind of how you would get it
uh and then some of the estimating
function stuff from um
gadombe and that whole line of research
i will say something about that
i don't know that anyone's ever bothered
to write it up directly i mean uh
oshkom has the uh doesn't have
inference under these kind of conditions
in his infant
if you know that paper the which is
greedy gq but
kind of from a stats point of view
uh so okay so there's a paper in
biometrica
by ash khan interfaith on um q learning
and infinite horizon cases
function approximation that is based on
uh an extension of greedy gq it's
uh i think it's a nice paper and it sets
everything up in terms of estimating
equations
which then you could use this stuff for
and i have one slide two slides on that
uh but then the the martingale
convergence stuff i think is scattered
across these estimating functions
literature and the
old stuff on like um stochastic
uh what do they call regression with
stochastic predictors or yeah
uh does infinite horizon case equals
multi-stage
i'm making the distinction between
finite horizon multi-stage and infinite
horizon
multi-stage or indefinite horizon
multi-stage at least
so i will talk about a two-stage case
but then also talk about the infinite
horizon case so the difference there
being
that in the finite case often we won't
exploit any markov structure
uh but we um and we'll use kind of just
regression-based dynamic programming
whereas in the infinite horizon case we
will use the mark off structure and then
we'll
we'll have to use uh some we'll have to
use that structure to then
construct an estimating equation so that
was a question in the chat
okay uh we are slightly making up for
time
uh so now i want to talk about um
a two-stage problem and this is going to
focus on
uh dynamic street regimes uh well at
least the first part just to motivate
the kind of questions we're trying to
answer
uh but then we'll just get back to
basically finite horizon dynamic
programming
but so uh dynamic treating regimes this
this is the tool used commonly in
precision medicine or personalized
medicine
and uh you know there's lots of examples
uh where we want to tailor treatment to
individual patient characteristics so um
i listed a bunch here basically all
chronic illness and even acute on this
um
and you know we it sort of represents
clinical practice as a multi-stage
decision problem that's how it models
that's what that's how we model that
decision process and
there's uh often a trade-off between
immediate and long-term outcomes or
proximal distal outcomes uh dynamic
troop regimes are just
the formalization of this decision
process as a sequence of functions
right so our decision rules and so you
have one decision or one for every time
point or one
uh that sort of comprises a policy and a
decision rule is just a map from the
information you have to a recommended
treatment
and the goal is to optimize some
cumulative clinical outcome so we're
going to look at finite horizon decision
problems
and we're not going to assume that
they're a mark off but we will assume we
have iid data
so just to give you a sense for what
these things look like this is an actual
dtr for patients patients school-aged
children with adhd
estimated from data in a clinical trial
and this is the kind of thing we want to
produce
with the algorithms i'm going to discuss
and the kind of inference we're going to
want to make
so uh again i want to get back to the
method so i'll try to go quickly here
but so this is just a simple
decision rule that you start in this
upper left and then you follow
the arrows so it says you know as a
child had and tolerated prior medication
if yes assign them low dose medication
as their first treatment
if no assign them low dose behavioral
modification therapy is their first
treatment
then you look to see if they're a
responder or not uh
and that's operationalized but i won't
get into that definition but if they are
a responder then just continue whatever
you were giving them
right so it's working don't change it
but if they aren't a responder
then you look to see are they adhering
to the treatment if they are
and they started off in low dose meds
intensify meds
if they're not adhering then add uh
behavioral modification therapy
and similarly you see parallel structure
here which is if they are adhering
uh then intensify behavioral
modification therapy
and otherwise add meds um and since five
means go you know twice a week instead
of once a week
i i thought uh you know at first maybe
just been
talking more intensely but uh that's not
true so
all right uh so what kind of inference
do we want to make so suppose we take
data and we estimate a rule like this
and i'll talk about the form of the data
in a bit but if we estimate a rule like
this
what do we want to know we want to know
things like
well which variables are important for
tailoring treatment so what do we need
to measure
a patient to decide what treatment to
give is an estimated rule like the one i
just showed you better than standard of
care or business as usual
which first line treatment is best for a
given patient this is something that the
people are often interested in
um because i think it has clinical
meaning uh
you know but the inference is
complicated by this now smooth this
problem again the non-regularity
uh causes the sampling distribution of
estimators not to converge uniformly
over the parameter space
and so this is one of those cases where
we um like the max we don't have any
regular asymptotically unbiased
estimators uh
for this or other s demands that are of
interest i mentioned here
and so uh as we've seen standard
inference methods perform poorly into
small samples
so just a road map for this part of the
tutorial i'm going to look at two-stage
q learning and i'm going to talk about
asymptotic bias reductions which is
something that shows up
that we haven't talked about yet and you
know are they worth it
and then um locally uniformly convergent
confidence intervals based on bounce
bound based intervals
and then i'll just say one thing i can
so this is the other place that i talk
about this i'll say one thing
unconditional confidence intervals
which was this a discussion that we had
uh
in a paper that we wrote um
we'd written something and then there
was a discussion and the discussion of
the discussion
uh but um through the setup we're going
to look now
uh data from a randomized clinical trial
to make things simple
local asymptotics as we've already
argued to study the finite sample
performance
we're going to use linear working models
for the q functions but we won't assume
that they're correct
and uh the same idea applies to other
estimators so those like um
there there are like say direct search
type methods and other things
the same issues arise in the same
intervals apply
[Music]
okay so here's the setup now so it's
slightly more complicated than before
but now for every every subject we have
a trajectory
x1 a1 x2 a2y so i indexes the subject i
equals one to n
they're drawn at iid for some
distribution p x1 is the information you
have before the first treatment is
assigned a1 is the first treatment so
now i'm coding at 0 1 because it'll be
convenient to do that
i'm talking about the bias x2 is interim
subject information so so information
collected during the course of the first
treatment
a2 is a binary second treatment and y is
an outcome measured at the end of the
study or the end of the observation
period so that higher is better
and we'll define the history h1 to be x1
and h2 would be x1 a1 x2
and so a policy or a strategy or a
dynamic treatment regime here
is a pair of functions pi 1 and pi 2
where pi t maps the history to the
action so the support of the history
the support of the action under which a
patient presenting with ht equals little
ht would be assigned treatment pi t of h
t
so just a map from history to actions
and it's a two stage decision problem
i think we are we are supposed to take a
break uh oh
sure okay yep i don't know if is this a
good
because i i thought you were introducing
new notations maybe it is a good
breaking point
yeah maybe we should stop here and then
i can sort of review this and then we
can go
[Music]
uh yeah i mean when we come back i'll
review this again and it will
that's a good idea yeah
[Music]
and i don't see any unanswered questions
anywhere so i think we're good with that
just one uh i just wanted to have a
clarification from you eric
you said that in this multi-stage
setting you will not assume
any markovian structure like basically
these
these x's x2 for instance given x1 x it
could evolve in
any way and the y especially the y the
the sort of the analog of the reward
this could depend on everything in in
all sorts of complicated way that's
right okay
what are bayesian methods be useful for
problems that you've discussed
uh yes absolutely uh
so uh the bayesian methods are
useful in a number of different ways
especially the adaptive randomization
it makes a lot of sense intuitive sense
to use them there
uh and also i think you know there's
there's some really nice
um working kind of non-parametric based
specifications
to like having like implicit groups of
patients that are somehow similar
uh there's the natural updating as they
accumulate i think
one of the reasons uh that we
i'm not talking about bayesian
approaches here is that the inference
does become harder to get
sort of to guarantee frequentest
sort of properties uh is more
complicated
uh and so that's one of the reasons i'm
not talking about it but i think
because for example what can happen is
the prior can end up kind of like
suppressing the
non-regularity issue and so
uh phil david has a paper on this from
the 90s where he looks at
select treatment selection problems
which are like the max of means problem
and what happens in a different sort of
bayesian approach is if you're not
careful
and so that's another issue is that you
also need to carefully kind of construct
your models to ensure that you were
going to be robust of local
perturbations
but yeah i think i think there's a lot
there's a ton of potential there or
hybrid methods where you use the
sampling distribution as a surrogate for
a posterior
and then you do things like thompson
sampling or you do things like um
uh maybe some kind of uh safe
uh thompson sampling or safe updating
i think yeah there's a lot of potential
[Music]
there
okay any other questions
kind of related to that i mean so we
were talking about adaptive clinical
trials before when you actually just
when you began your talk
i keep hearing things like bayesian
adaptive clinical trials is that just a
kind of a
methodology within adaptive clinical
trial design
yeah so they're there you might have a
posterior probability that a given
treatment is optimal
uh given a patient's characteristics and
all the data you've seen so far
so uh or it may be it may be something
like
just thompson sampling in that sense or
there might be some other kind of
adjustment where you you
truncate the probability or you um
you have some other kind of adjustment
and then there's also the bayesian
uh there are also bayesian adaptive
designs where the
you look at the posterior information
gain basically
uh as a function of what you have the
information you have so far so if you
could do like active learning
and you could select x's for example you
might recruit patients that maximize
information gain for your model
so you look at the the at the distance
between the prior and the posterior
under like
each patient you might recruit or like
um
or each or treatments also potentially
yeah
yeah we can stop now the zoom will just
be on uh it usually just stays on and
this break is a longer one because
approximately corresponds to lunchtime
time in
the pacific time zone so we'll just
reconvene
at uh it's 2 30 here it's 11 30
in california so 12 30 there and
at 3 30 in eastern okay is this uh is
this at the right level so far are we
are we is it too fast or too slow or is
it okay
based on the questions i feel we're
going okay like i think as long as
people are still asking questions means
if
someone's following them